[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is poppin it is Monday November
21st almost at 22nd it is the 21st
busy week what are you guys doing for
Thanksgiving you flying somewhere
hopefully you're not it's gonna be a
busy day travel 55 million Americans
estimated to be traveling around on this
turkey day
um yeah man it's gonna be a nice little
turkey day over the lockdowns and the
restrictions the holidays haven't been
the same but it's gonna be popping this
year Dad it's gonna be popping people
can be out traveling they have Black
Friday here's a question for everybody
out there it's Black Friday still a
thing because now everybody's buying
stuff non-stop 365 days a year online so
does Black Friday even matter
is it even a thing anymore now I worked
with several companies and they're
hoping that Black Friday is still a
thing
I don't know I guess the audience
conditioned you know people the the
society's condition that Black Friday
get deals I get the biggest deals is
that Amazon thing they do yeah Amazon
does like that big deal yeah Prime day
right that's their big thing but outside
that I mean it's not like Walmart's
slash in prices on a flat screen maybe
they I don't know maybe they are there's
always videos that pop up every year
there's still videos yeah yeah like
Walmart you know just getting beat up
for like a tickle me almost
I get it man I get inflation your kid
wants to tickle me ammo there's three
left some dude grabs it you know you're
kidding me broken-hearted
them the rules you're gonna have to get
a black eye Daddy can I have my kid
crying on Christmas
um we're doing thick Thursday that's
right I'm dropping the new thick boy
merch on Thursday because I truly
believe that Black Friday although
people are conditioned to look for deals
on Friday I don't think it matters when
you drop it I feel like everybody's
gonna be sitting around you're with your
friends you're with your family people
are gonna be on their phones because
we're addicted to our phones around a
group of people guaranteed I think it's
a good time to drop it on Thursday do a
little different everybody doing Black
Friday all right I think all Fridays
matter okay not just Black Friday I like
all Fridays that's how we do it here
baby that's how we do it here you guys
out there just hoping banking on Black
Friday how about thick Thursday oh it's
Thanksgiving you bet your sweet thick
ass it is we're doing thick Thursday
Thanksgiving and we are dropping my
favorite merch I've ever done it's by
far the best quality I'm rocking the
military it's it's kind of the Padres
but it's also it's a it's more special
than that but but it is the exact same
quality you get when the you purchase an
authentic jersey from the MLP the exact
same qualities it is not so's and
nowhere near the price of those we doing
deals all the time at thick boy so yeah
this one's the military inspired themed
MLB jersey thick boy Jersey has patches
on both sleeves sewn in sewn in camo
sewn in patch where's the patch sewn in
patch here the thick Boy Nation
authentic patch and then uh so you got
this one and then we're also dropping uh
a straight up brown and yellow one also
sewn in matching hoodies Brown hoodie
military hoodie and then two uh thick
boy trucker hats as well that match the
baseball uniforms that is going down
early early we're talking 6 a.m Pacific
Time on thick Thursday that's this
mother Trucking Thursday baby it's going
down I'm looking forward to it man so
it's a gift that keeps on giving you'd
get in time before Christmas so if your
friends are thick out there go ahead and
get them all this stuff and then they're
doing a big old deal on all the
remaining inventory big deal I forget
what they're doing but it's gonna be
fantastic that's thick Thursday this
Thursday we're sitting around with your
family friends all hopped up on
cranberry sauce and stuffing go ahead
and jump on over to thickboy.com it'll
be there for you and then you're like
man these kids are driving me nuts which
I had some tasty beverage to wash it
down with cool tiger think is available
also and they're doing the deal on
shipping uh you get five dollars off
shipping and that is till January 1st so
throughout the rest of the year if you
go to thickboy.com our Distributors are
bourbon Outfitters and uh thinkboy.com
just click on tiger thick they're doing
it you don't need to enter any promo
code nothing they automatically do it
when you check out you get five dollars
off I think the best tasting Whiskey on
the planet and uh if you ask my friends
in Milwaukee they would say the same
they would say the exact same Milwaukee
likes themselves some
some whiskey man I went to the
Harley-Davidson Museum you ever been to
Harley Davidson museum
there's me and David look at me and Dave
just doing our thing man
and that's that's that that's a
three-wheeler I gotta be honest I want
one
I feel like it's safer than a regular
two-wheel motorcycle it's big enough
where cars can still see you Sun's in
your face wind in your face I had David
with his arms wrapped around me
does me rocking my Harley-Davidson
Jersey
yeah the Harley Davidson museum was
interesting this guy said [ __ ] I want to
go and find a ride well 80 bucks for
Uber God damn where do you live dude
and that that venue Milwaukee improv
I've so I've played Milwaukee before I
played the uh a theater there uh the
Turner Hall which is connected to the
Pap's theater so it's the Turner Hall
which is I don't know five years ago
probably and because uh I think Joey
Diaz is doing the paps one so his pass
was the big boy there's Turner Hall
which is good but perhaps it's like
we're Bert and Tom and Joey Diaz play so
I was next door to that
um at the Turner Hall that was the last
time I was in Milwaukee this is a brand
new improv the Milwaukee improv and my
God man it is the best improv in the
nation it's the newest so you know they
can put some
some effort into it so it's the most
updated but man it is so dope you've
been all over too Mark how nice was that
improv out of all of them man nuts but
it's on the outside technically you say
it's Milwaukee but it's on the outside
skirts a little bit out there probably
20 minutes outside downtown
uh in the ritzy area I guess you know
dude I had a cop come up to me at the
meet and greet and he goes what are you
doing after this man I was like uh not
much what's up I was like well I don't
go out and he's like oh man he's like
I've been a cop for this many years he's
like I got stuff about Dahmer that they
don't tell you guys it's worse than you
think oh man
yeah as much as I would love to have
drinks and talk about this I'm just
exhausted and I have a 4 a.m flight
because I come back and watch my kid
play [ __ ] soccer it was the worst
Mexican you've ever seen play soccer
it's just not his thing it's not his
thing
it's a World Cup World Cup is popping
my son's school they let him wear uh
soccer jerseys today I mean his mom had
a battle royale for what Jersey he was
going to wear because I'm English baby
my team's England right yes we don't do
soccer here we do freaking
um you know we do football basketball
here but England they love it they
freaking love it so I rock it with
England Tiger's so serious there right
now the freaking bosty looks like Nate
Diaz I don't know why he's putting his
fist up like that
um look how big his hands are but uh in
his feet Jesus Christ but uh it means
mom got into it she wanted to wear
Mexico Jersey owned where the England
Jersey and then uh we settled on him
just wearing his team soccer jersey
compromised you know compromised but uh
let's get into it man as far as the
fights go oh as far as the news I
couldn't say it last week because the
the ink wasn't even dry yet but we have
a very special Calabasas fight companion
December 9th we are teaming up with bar
stool Sports teaming up with rough and
rowdy that's their crazy insane
entertaining Fight League and uh we're
doing a cal bass fight companion with
Joey Diaz Theo Von and Rampage Jackson
and then also we'll be watching the
rough and rowdy 19 which takes place in
New England
um it says right from rally 19 New
England but says December 9th Providence
Rhode Island you're from the East Coast
describe that to me Casey
Rhode Island's New England
yeah
this is right here
something Pavilion Providence explain
that to me dude because I thought Rhode
Island was its own
thing it is a state so the New England
is made up of a few States oh word did
you know that chin I mean I am did you
know that Mark
perhaps it's kind of like you would say
the Southwest the Pacific Northwest like
it's more New England's more of a region
interesting
because I was like hold up is that it
says New England within Providence Rhode
Island
people always goes like hey dumbass
the Patriots Yeah well well no you
should know this Golden State
Golden State Warriors it's kind of like
just Northern Cali it's like Golden
State like they represent like San Jose
San Francisco Oakland yeah they're not a
city it's about the only teams right
but
that's about it I didn't know that so
long story short I just dedicated New
England's not just a you know specific
thing
um so that's in Province Rhode Island
December 9th it's funny I'll be out
there the week before don't show that
the counter connection the first to the
third so then bar stools then there the
Fong week but I will be here in
Calabasas California doing one of the
greatest fight campaigns of all time
with the great and one of my best
friends the Rat King Theo Von the
[ __ ] Phenom Joey Diaz coming all the
way from Jersey he's my first call I
said Joe I need you man [ __ ] sucker I
don't want to come to [ __ ] L.A what's
in L.A I said I know I know you hate LA
but hear me out here I partnered up with
Barstool I need a big hitter we've
you've done commands with me and Rogan
before come on dude come out because
[ __ ] I'm in I'm in I'm in I'm not
staying there all [ __ ] week though I
think I don't need you for I just need
you for Friday how [ __ ] long is this
thing uh like a few hours man then we
get to whatever Hotel flight all right
I'm [ __ ] I love you brother all right
man love you
so he's coming out surprise he said yes
all the way from Jersey to get him to
come to [ __ ] La is a big deal
you got Theo Von too and then of course
Rampage Jackson you need a legit fighter
on there and Rampage is funny as hell
yeah he's great I love his stories so
give me a fun one man so you have that
Friday December 9th then on the 10th you
have the big UFC was it you see 282.
and uh you got the light heavyweight
championship belt on the line then we're
also doing a fight Pain for that with
special guests you got Brian Callan Sam
Tripoli and we have another very special
guest there so it's gonna be a busy
weekend boys case hydrate up buddy you
almost died when we did the one on the
road you almost died yeah that card's
fun UFC 282 is pretty stacked super
stuck you know it's stacked it's just
not I mean it's such a good card it the
the main card to me is one of my
favorites this year it's so [ __ ] good
but it's not like
I know you want you won't say it's uh as
a kid it's not sexy you don't say oh man
this thing is lit unless you're like
hard caucus go up chin so you got your
main event
you have uh Yuri verse Glover right and
you're the minus 195 favorite there many
of yon versus magamed right and magmed
minus 225 that's a tough fight for John
that mogmod Jesus Christ you thought
he'd be yeah I thought be the other way
around oh no way no way no oh I don't
know who the [ __ ] gonna be magma he's
a problem Russian right and then uh you
have Patty pimlet who's
the biggest name on the card huh it's
fair to say even though he's not even
ranked isn't that crazy first Jared
Gordon not an easy easy yeah for sure
now he's a slight favorite minus 165
then this fight's phenomenal Robbie
Lawler pentanibio fantastic and then you
got another hot one Bryce Flat Earth
Mitchell verse uh diporia yeah great
fight great [ __ ] fight none the
prelims you got Gus Finn OSP two old
school boys doing it
that's a good fight God damn till needs
a win and then you have Rose and shrook
and Krista caucus
Felix docus Dukakis
you have uh the Philly cop doing the
damn thing oh man on the earth how dare
they treat my boy Edmond
shabazian like this
put them on the [ __ ] earlier prelims
and Alex Hernandez it's a stack card
Chris Curtis Joaquin Buckley's great TJ
Browner Silva they're all good men
they're good cards yeah that's a great
card I'm excited for that one so you
have the Mayhem from rough and rowdy
December 9th they have the fight command
December 10th the fight Japan December
10th you can watch it live and we do it
but we'll be available to everyone two
or three days after it goes live just so
we don't destroy the bar stool companion
that's the plan but I'll announce that
as we get closer so I'm looking forward
to it man I've been with bar stool
as far as like being on the shows and
stuff I don't know how many years now
long long time and when they did rough
and rowdy we've been trying to get this
deal together for a while then finally
just all worked out man here we are
so I'm looking forward to it man are
those little people
that is the small person yes
thank goodness good idea thank you
all right family let's take a little
break for me just chatting your air off
and you guys probably counting down the
days till it's Thanksgiving because it
is the holiday season and I'll be giving
thanks to our friends over at manscape
that's right manscaped everyone loves
turkey and stuffing but you'll be
looking like dessert with the Help from
My Friends at manscape their performance
package 4.0 the leaders in below the
waist grooming have blessed you with the
ultimate Thanksgiving dinner topic tell
your in-laws about your new Cutting Edge
ball trimmering gift yourself or your
man in your life the ultimate men's
hygiene bundle trim your pumpkins and
save 20 off with free shipping by going
to manscape.com
think your holiday spread is good check
it out it's time to give my friends at
manscape performance package 4.0 as I
like to call it the perfect package for
your package inside this freaking 4.0
package you'll find their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer the weed whacker ear nose hair
trimmer crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver toner performance by boxer
briefs and a travel bag to put all your
goodies your balls are going to say man
holiday came early baby we're so smooth
everyone loves us that's right we got
you man we got you covered and also they
have body wash all right there's new
signature body buffer gives you the
lather and wrench your body deserves all
right man and no hygiene routine is
complete without manscape signature
deodorant as well a couple swipes of
this and you'll be feeling oh so crisp
gift and manscape is the ultimate hack
to become the family favorite if your
stepmom hates you give your dad the
ultimate package all right save 20 off
and free shipping by going to
manscape.com job that's right 20 and
free shipping by going to manscape.com
be thankful this holiday season for the
best gift of all from manscape your
balls will thank you listen up kiddos
another ad for you and then we'll get
back to the program here to talk to you
about my friends at Rogue if you're a
regular viewer you already know how much
your thick friend here loves Rogue
nicotine I don't do anything without
using some of their pouches every single
day I use them on podcasts if I'm
working out riding my bike doing stand
up before I go on stage after I get on
stage you see me taking the meet and
greet pictures because I go back to the
Green Room put them in my lip then take
pictures I'm obsessed with them my
favorite favorite flavor I started with
is mango but then I started mixing up I
get the berry I get the honey lemon
right now I'm all about the Apple all
right beyond the pouches Rogue also
makes other nicotine products like gum
tablets lozenges we got you covered
whatever you like to eat your nicotine
my friends at Rogue got you covered
right I'm a pouch guy but I like to mix
it up I like to switch it up with a
little uh maybe a little freaking uh gum
here and there on the road maybe a
little tablet bring it on the plane with
me I take it everywhere on the flights
comic clubs no restrictions I don't have
to worry about Rogue is my go-to source
for nicotine all right and I love it I
reached out to them be part of my show
because I use Rogue more than any other
product and so I'm trying to give back
to you guys it's fantastic if you want
to try uh the pouches like me or the
gums or tablets every team go to
roguenickteam.com that's r-o-g-u-e
nicotine.com use the code rogue20 you
get 20 off your order again that's Rogue
20 for 20 off your order all right it's
the best of the best it's the best
nicotine on the planet we're talking
about Rogue nicotine baby all right
underage sale is prohibited warning this
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical for more information
visit roguenicketing.com
now let's get back to the program
uh but outside that fight wise I mean
last last week's fight night you know
with the main event getting called off
with Derek Lewis is a freaking [ __ ] show
for the UFC so they bumped up Kennedy
and Cuda Libra
um you know the card was anything
special that's tough when you lose the
main event the day I mean yeah those
numbers must have been awful for them
awful the rebook that and Derek Lewis it
wasn't Cove or anything like that and I
guess he's cleared now but I wonder what
it was but it said stomach issues yeah
maybe food poisoning or something like
that because it could to be that bad for
a fighter Dropout day of the main event
made way too and everything so yeah I
know I know
it's all interesting by far the best
fight over the weekend was and I keep
telling you guys this and you've seen
all over social media on thick boy on
mine we talked about on the show best
fights by far
was the one Championship on Amazon the
one Championship Amazon I think this is
the fourth one
and he had the young man Christian Lee
what is trying to be a double champ
champ and he got it done weird it's like
somebody called it the max Holloway
retweeted it
your boy called it from The Green Room
right before I go on stage Michael Zell
you want to do a prediction I'm like
yeah we got to be quick with it but I
said late TKO for my boy
Christian Lee and the young man got it
done now he's a double champ champ
if you're hurt if only a sister yeah
dude the guy he's fighting's a Savage
Russian Savage
right yeah I think so check this out
she got dropped bad there
[Applause]
how tough is this family dude
oh my God he's in trouble
this was UFC they stop it
and that's Herb Dean too
my God he's got his ass came back dude
insane dude insane
get some Bellator over the weekend
off got it done against put uh Pitbull
kind of Molly whopped him Cranston lost
decision
man that uh Usman uh no Margaret Madoff
is a Savage 50-44 out of two judges he
beat the brakes up uh Pitbull beat the
brakes off of them
a lot of day stands taking over
all right chin let's get into it what do
you got there all right not a ton going
on this week slow week for the fight
game dude slow week Thanksgiving dude I
was looking forward to Thanksgiving I
get yeah not only do I have Thanksgiving
but then I also have Boston's birthday
when's it uh 26th so it's not all right
we'll celebrate his birthday on Saturday
with those little friends also friends
came over the house also my question for
my girls like are these friends or they
just go to school with them because he's
two he's so young right I mean it could
be anyone do you guys do uh Thanksgiving
at your place yeah oh it's dope yeah
yeah about to lay the law down man
because maybe the Mexicans they're
trying to have soup and [ __ ] so I forget
what the hell you call it menudo yeah
you know I will not have in my house
disgusting but pozole
yeah some pozole posole yeah they'll try
having pozole and they've done it the
last like three or four years bro
I am 39 years old I cannot have soup for
dinner on Thanksgiving it's just a piece
though well I have other food there too
not really they just have the soup there
and then they put the meat in like you
want more meat I'm like no [ __ ] I need
some mashed potatoes and turkey I am
white these kids are half white put
football on get the pumpkin pie out what
are we doing here they can't be braids
like this what are we doing man
because what does Mexico do during
Thanksgiving
I think they do things
that's our thing man yeah
cultural appropriation man trying to
take over Thanksgiving I ain't having it
not up in here not never
so we doing a regular man I got we got
the turkey in the fridge right now
get that stuff in I'll make my gravy I
got the recipe for my grandma holler all
right a little cranberry a little pecan
pie my favorite those are awesome you
know my teeth hurts like I just gotta
suck it I suck on the slices suck them
so Fizzles out because my teeth hurt you
gotta try with vanilla ice cream I'm
telling you put ice cream on it it's so
good if the see dude you know what
that's like chin that's like uh taking
like a nice whiskey like a tiger steak
and then you you're like oh you want an
old fashioned get out of my face dude
get out of my freaking face
I'm back drinking Sunday nights now so I
basically drink every day so that's cool
because uh yellow stones on Sundays ah
you still haven't got into a chin you
would have it no yeah and then the Tulsa
King was Sylvester Stallone the same
writer Taylor Sheridan wrote that the
Tulsa King so he's a mob guy from like
Brooklyn New York and he goes away for
25 years because he didn't rat on his
boss and then he gets out like cool
things were not ratting on us and saving
the entire family uh we're gonna send
you to Tulsa
and so it's like this like old school
like mob guy he doesn't get like cell
phones and it's it's hey it's funny yeah
especially great in it it's Taylor
shared it doesn't miss
it's like if it's like if The Sopranos
and Yellowstone had a baby
you didn't like Sopranos though right no
I thought it was good it's not the top
three for me people you know jack off to
it is 1883 still going right now no
they're doing a 1930 something one now
eight oh yeah 18 it's demographic I'm a
huge team man that's good they're
bringing that they're bringing them up
so Taylor should has four shows now
because it's that 1883 is that like 1993
just kidding 19 whatever's 33
Yellowstone then he has uh Tulsa Tulsa
King Tulsa King damn good I'm only two
episodes in but it's good it's on what
Netflix or no uh Paramount but it's on
regular TV too
get that Paramount subscription I know I
gotta start subscribing finally saw the
scary movie smile too was it good or not
good really good good good scary movie
did I think it's a little cheesy when
they finally come face to face but good
movie
there's a movie I wanted to tell you
about what um Justin long do you know
what I'm talking about yeah the the
scary movie that he was in I saw it was
really really cool hold on don't even
tell me you're talking about
um oh
not the old one Jeepers Creepers what do
you got them beepers Jeepers Creepers no
no he wasn't that but Jesus creepers
what do you got them beepers
that's from the movie I don't know why
they play that song it's so old school
it's like Jeepers Creepers he got them
beepers so you have to watch this movie
barbarian barbarian yeah don't hit don't
read about it just watch it it's so
freaking good that bill guy is from uh
it he's the clowning it there you go
yeah he's really the movies dude you
have to watch it is it good it's so good
and it's like it was kind of like a
sleeper
I want to take the kiddos to a movie
there's nothing out right now like
there's uh Black Panther too that's like
the big but usually like during
Christmas and holidays they load it up
because you know people go to the movies
there ain't [ __ ] at the theater nothing
I don't like superhero movies I tried
watching the new uh
Thor on the plane from Milwaukee I never
liked it just don't I just can't get in
when he's flying around and [ __ ] like
I'm out yeah I'm out oh but you watch
dragons yeah dude I believe more and
Dragons Black Adam I have no desire to
see same look there's nothing dude
nothing
Hollywood's like oh
terrified two supposed to be late can't
take my kids to that
my boy Frank Grillo is in Lamborghini
what the hell I think that comes out on
uh
yeah
oh yeah but he's a killer oh yeah
but they usually they they drop some I
know around the signs Mashers man
Jo koi Easter Sunday it's been out for a
hot second yeah but there's nothing dude
break time as they say on the trolls
movie hug time it's break time and a lot
of y'all out there need to step your
game up man you get more focused and you
get in that flow State what if I told
you you do it in two simple pills that's
right we're talking about nootropics if
you don't want nootropics is look it up
and when you look it up you can see one
brand that gets brought up a ton that's
my friends that on it on it my friends
at on it create the best nootropic on
the planet and get you into that flow
State my friend Joe Rogan says it helped
them form better sentences when he's
talking he's one of the main driving
forces behind Alpha Brain that's how
much he believes in it and they have
even more intense Alpha Brain without
for bringing the Black Label so if
you've been using Alpha Brain you want
to step your game up use the Black Label
it's more concentrated more powerful
Alpha Brain but if you're a newbie your
rookies stick to the basic Alpha Brain
all right they've already sold over a
million freaking bottles and here's the
thing on it so confident you're gonna
love it if you don't you get your money
back you give them two weeks at that
point you don't love it Alpha brain's
not fit for you oh okay just tell them
why and they refund your money on the
spot no return necessary you can save 10
off your entire order at onit.com you
get 10 off when you go to audit.com
Alpha Brain ten percent off Warrior bars
protein powders fish oils workout gear
workout freaking merch whatever you want
to get your thick body in shape on it
got you covered but they just happen to
offer the best nootropics on the planet
we're talking about Alpha Brain you can
pick Alpha Brain up at your local
Walmart or help your boy out go to
honor.com shop save temps off your
entire order on it all right on it.com
shop happy holidays all right give me
those current events
all right so over the weekend this also
happened Houston has Houston Alexander
old school UFC guy and Joey Beltran
who's also old school UFC guy so he was
Houston Alexander dropped him
well that jab hurt yeah that jab hurt
[Applause]
I mean puts him in the ropes right here
man that bare Knuckles that jab just
messed this whole looks like an orbital
problem
I wonder if we can show this video maybe
we'll just put the just audio thing yeah
yeah all right probably not yeah so
Houston Alexander one now being in
flagged lately he's 3-0 on the beat and
then bare knuckle fighting championship
and I mean how much bigger is she used
to I mean probably find it light heavy
I'm saying for Mike Perry that'd be a
fun fight
but Houston's a lot bigger you know I
take Perry on that one though
younger quicker it's hard
um
this is cool this is a
I don't know how to say his name how
long
on song from more Championship he played
tribute he was uh
he was buddies with the rumble Johnson
so he did that when he won his fight he
pulled out a picture and that's cool man
super cool
yeah that's super sad I saw Josh
Thompson getting choked up on the
Bellator broadcast too where he did like
a tribute to rumble yeah I swear to
Scott coker's like I don't know who's
sick God damn Scott oh no he did I think
he mentioned something about it before
but I mean he probably didn't know it
was that's it yeah yeah
yeah it sucks
um also Vitor Belfort was supposed to
fight uh
Ramen right but then
fell out I called it though because I
was like man I've seen anything on this
I was like in his Vitor posted anything
about it and then sure enough next day
pulls out pulls out and then Greg Hardy
came in and Greg Hardy knocked out uh
did he knock him out well he knocked him
down uh once and then I think he what's
that hold on let's see
these are the highlights I'm not sure if
we can play this but please play it safe
yeah you keep getting that's why he
drops him here
boom right on the chin
and then uh Ramen missed weight too
Rockman straight up missed weight
oh caught him there
and Greg Hardy came in heavy too he
looks so gigantic yeah he's so big yeah
super big that boy can be thick when he
retires hmm
so he won uh so uh
Harley came in not go up Jim go for me
keep going let me see what it says so
hardy who weighed in 94 pounds heavier
than Rockland Junior what the
they just started I just need somebody
to freaking jump in Jesus Christ he
ended up beating them yeah
so you end up winning uh by decision
let's look right on I should have looked
that up earlier I mean impressive for
Hardy right even though he's way bigger
but still
decision
interesting yeah but he dropped him so
good for a Greg Hardy man yeah out of
nowhere but 94 pounds heavier that's
insane that's oh yeah
fighting a 205 in the UFC nuts yeah so
shiny Aoki I remember Yoshino Kami oh
yeah yeah they both lost their one
championship fights over the weekend as
well um
um this one here Daniel Kelly she has
beef with Angela Lee for a while now so
she was calling her out after she won
this past weekend as well she's a little
badass man yeah
I think that's a great fight hell yeah
I'm in for it yeah
and Cosmo Alexander he retired
he won his fight yeah I was fighting the
second round and what's cool about the
this one is like uh
uh I guess shot tree 50 000. uh
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
but uh thanks for 20 years of your hard
work is fifty thousand dollars dude 50k
is great man yeah they could have done
more though huh yeah so I started
researching Rod tank even more now T1
his last fight interesting super
interesting story so he had his like a
coach that believed in him when he
didn't believe in himself
uh got him to train God he said he could
be a world champion he passed away
suddenly from a heart attack and then
after like two years later raw Tank's
dad had stage three cancer so to do that
while he's fighting and he still became
a champion Jesus Christ yeah and then I
think he's his dad is good now oh really
yeah I think so yeah wow yeah right
thing one this weekend yeah super cool
story with rotting you want to play a
little bit of this I think we can do
this right one championship
I don't know
damn it all right we'll just bypass this
for now
um see if that's him with his dad
that's crazy yeah damn his dad is dark
yep
and small
yeah all right so this happened Dylan
danis has been getting into a lot of
trouble lately Dylan got straight up
dude but he the way he handle it was
really dope yeah I'll show you though
let's see what he did can we play this
well I'll just show you real quick yeah
please but this is him with KSI so we're
watching Dylan Dennis and KSI KSA has a
cowboy hat on which I'm not mad at Dylan
has a great very Theo Vonage mullet
let's do this
so that's a little scuffle nothing big
that builds the fight yeah
so he kind of he went to like flick his
hat off it looked like and this is
outside with um I'm pretty sure we can
play this because it's on TMZ but this
is outside with that guy the T-Rex guy
oh this is T-Rex yeah but he's an actual
MMA fighter yeah he fought for Bellator
so this is him outside and this is I
like how uh Dylan Dallas handles himself
here I'll just play for you
this is pretty boy Taylor
isn't it weird these guys do this for
attention
[Music]
because it's going down to his brother
he's the MVP look at his brother not a
fighter right and his brother oh good
shot too
Leah's brother though his brother gets
cold [ __ ] from behind oh oh God
I got sucked in my mouth
real quick he had an interview with you
you see him out of breath after a fight
he handled himself really well he was
like oh whatever he got punched in the
face too yeah
yeah that's what these boys do man yeah
I think the thing with dill knows you're
talking about like
Savage Jiu Jitsu player like monster
dude
yeah interesting after all that I
shouldn't see that because you know
Dylan's not exactly known for striking
and obviously as the Jitsu come to shoot
submit them in three seconds but it's
not
and KSI did really well with Logan Paul
so I think he's gonna definitely win
yeah KSI these guys that come over the
box and I just it's so interesting to me
because like at KSI and Logan's
different than uh Jake Paul you know
it's interesting yeah I mean Logan
lasted pretty well with Mayweather
whatever that was but he actually lasted
yeah
yeah like the KSI is Logan Paul is a
little different than Jake
yeah I don't know what's gonna happen
there I'm pretty sure KSI is gonna win
but we'll see
so this is Rogan
um saying that Alex pajer who just beat
Israel he said that uh
that cutting weight thing is basically
sanctioning cheating because he cuts
massive amounts he's he was enormous on
that fight remember yeah but he's
compromised too I don't agree with that
it's also it's what wrestling's been
doing for years yeah but he said that
everyone does it but it just his
opinions it's still sanctioning cheating
but everyone does it hmm
I mean it can be an advantage right
especially if you're good at it but uh
with pierra
you know I I wouldn't call it cheating
you know I wouldn't call it cheating no
because they may wait yeah he they
literally weigh the same on the scale
and then he blooms back up if anything
you would that's what makes Pierre kind
of special is he can cut that weight and
he still had cardio for five rounds most
guys cut all that weight by that fifth
round of screwed
uh recent episode of JRE
what do you say with Stevo with Stevo
yeah see what aspirin whether it's troop
here was really 220 pounds against uh
Izzy so he could have been yeah he
certainly gets above that in between
fights and he has a hard time making 85.
it's a [ __ ] thing especially
sanction it really is but everybody does
it Izzy barely does it when Izzy moved
out to fight Jan at lightweight he
weighed 194. it's crazy because John's
is a giant light heavyweight
John is a powerful guy
interesting it's definitely an advantage
you know
if but Advantage early on usually as the
fight goes on it's not but Pierre didn't
seem to fade away with it no he came out
strong to put him away
standing TKO
uh this is Alex pajer talking about
Israel because I get I guess he's saying
that Israel is making excuses for his
loss
excuse and the referee stop the finally
you have to thank him for saving life we
were with your head down look at the
ground I only need one or two more hits
to connect good knee to your face so we
wouldn't know the outcome as I said at
that point in the video you were a great
opponent I respect you for that assume
your mistakes along with your team
without taking away from my merits you
have one more chance you're next
not if homside gets his way I don't
think the UFC would be so amazing though
I don't think or the UFC might because
they didn't call Izzy bike right when
you're ready to do this thing he's like
man I'm having surgery I'll be out this
long I'm like oh we ain't waiting but
then it would ruin that right
Izzy uh PR fight no matter what even if
Pierre has the belt or not
yeah yeah Hamza would be a handful for
so funny yeah
hopefully they do it yeah
all right over him got popped again
hey glory be cool
they're obviously denying anything that
was a performance enhancing but I don't
know I guess there's an investigation
problem with over him on this how dare
you guys
so they're gonna take away his win I
don't know they're still going to
investigate so
they're saying it's not a substance
that's performance enhancing I don't
know what it is
and that's his picture before the fight
so I'm pretty sure
of course these awesome stuff yeah
freaking out and to get popped that
means but Glory what are you doing I
know how dare you guys
that's like when the the Olympia uh
tested guys
an Olympia tested guys and when WWE when
a w WWE guy gets popped it's like oh
they they're trying to get rid of them I
mean where are we doing it yeah
they're making too much Power Glory I
know just let him they're probably all
I'm not I don't know whatever okay so uh
you're talking about Comsat Hamza was
laughing at the fact that pajera he just
got his brown belt after finishing or
after winning the fight with Israel
which is interesting what what is so if
Brown is like next to black or what is
this okay yes yeah so his code's hard to
get to gotcha yeah his coach is saying
like you know you survived your ground
game you survived that it's instantly
giving guy a brown boat saying you
survived yeah this usually not how it
works but you know good for him
so they survived that and in the end he
stood on his feet knocked out it takes a
very high level guy in The Head and the
Heart and the technique because that I
believe in our kids believe that he went
to reward him with a brown belt yes
surviving is really not
and then this hamzat's reaction hand to
face laughing emojis
yeah
like if you entered the brown uh
grappling tournament like in ADCC or IBG
destroyed right because most brahmots
are just black belts that don't have as
long as the tenure they haven't been
doing as long but I mean brown belt most
brown belts should be black belts but
depending on the school it takes a few
more years for them they're savages
the purple belts would be tough for
Pierre
uh how many belts is that below brown
purple purple's the one below brown but
even the purple like a a good purple
like a per depending if you're like
kenzos or henners or you know Amal
eastons like usually a purple belt and a
lot of skills would be a black belt but
they don't they it's hard to get to that
black belt level it takes years years
and years how many years did it take you
to get to uh
technically I get my black belt after I
submitted mitrion with that darsh choke
um [ __ ] 10 years damn
that's cool yeah man oh yeah
I was a brown for a hot second though
and that's how it works use your brown
belt for a long time
just depends on the school there's just
there's different levels like there's
different levels at purple at school
you're from at Brown at black there's
different black belts so you say oh I
got my black belt from henzo or John Dan
or Eddie probably like oh [ __ ] wow
because you know that's the real deal
and some people just get a black belt
because they've been doing it for so
long they probably can't compete with
those other gyms but they've been doing
it for whatever 15 years they just give
them black belt interesting
all right
um this is this happened recently I
guess khabib was talking I'm not sure
what event this is well it says in
Toronto but could we did an interview
and he mentioned how like um Conor said
he said he didn't mention his name
because someone said before you know
we're taking over and then he's saying
that we're taking over now because he
has Champions yeah yeah so then um
because it was his cousin won in the
Builder right that's his cousin I think
that's his cousin I think so I fight on
your father's plan
so I felt on your first plan it's never
complete because you quit and ran
brother God bless I'm still here if you
want to go again but your fear of defeat
means you've already lost run from it
all you want we all lose in the end
death takes us all I fear nothing but
God
that's what Connor said no yeah after
hearing what you know khabib said about
the whole taking over thing I mean
because he's not lying there no he is
yeah those things Russians are a problem
yeah
all right
um
this is Michael Chandler your boy
talking about the BMF belt he wants to
fight for him as well for that belt
because he believes he's the I don't
know to him he considers himself like
the baddest guy as far as fighting and
entertainment so he wants to fight
jorgeous yeah
let me see if I can find that video
there it is but you tell me who the BMF
is right now in the UFC
you tell me who the BMF is you tell me
who the fans if we did a poll right now
the Sim talked in a bread akimoto
that wouldn't that wouldn't get the
juices flown to the entire mixed martial
arts World Michael Chandler versus
George mosvidov for the BMF belt The
Rock walking in with it over his
shoulder and then handed it to me 15
minutes later
he's trying to get a big fight so is uh
just import it so Chandler I know
Chandler called out
um Jorge and they also called out Connor
and then Dustin was like man I think uh
Darius deserves it but I'm not I'm
looking for a bigger side yeah I know I
told you guys it was gonna happen
it'd be the thing to do but it's just
not poor dear use man I know I don't
know what it is real shame yeah
um all right so fader is retiring to
fight is gonna be rematched with Ryan
Bader at Bellator 290 I think that's in
February and where's that at I think
locally it's Inglewood oh damn it's here
yeah so yeah Inglewood California The
Forum wow
interesting
that's dope so if we don't do a fight
companion I'll probably just go you're
gonna go yeah if we don't do a five
commandment we probably won't do a fight
okay oh no it's February 4th that's the
big UFC too
which one is I think I might be in
Austin for that doing a companion
in Austin very forth is a big UFC
Australia Whitaker oh Chicago
pretty sure that same day let's see
February 11th oh it's February so the
week after oh there you go perfect yeah
that is a huge card though huge card
interesting
oh yeah this is dope such card yair Josh
oh you're more Tyson too
Jimmy crew wants them at midfield's a
good one
cool that's a good card
bait or fader and let faders last hurray
yeah
that's what he wanted apparently yeah
nope Fedor wanted either Metreon or
Bader
um so we talked about Anthony T-Rex
earlier I guess he announced that he's
going to be fighting Floyd Mayweather
what is going on I don't know what's
going on but then there you know he's in
the news a lot lately because he's in
these little Street scuffles
interesting
yeah
um so Alex bahia's sister she fought
over the weekend and her first MMA fight
and she lost the decision but she
dropped the girl
early on she's scary too yeah she has
power
dropped her there
damn she ended up losing yeah did the
girl drop version I don't think she
dropped her Jesus Christ
oh yeah
this is the LFA yep interesting yeah but
she lost so
um it's just an update on Aaron Pico and
her shoulder popped out he had surgery
successful so he should be back within
six to eight months him and TJ same
trainer shoulder problems let's answer
the train I'm saying wow dude
interesting two shoulder surgeries
and TJ's is terrible
oh this one's pretty crazy so uh in New
Jersey
it says New Jersey gambling Authority
banned Sports books from taking bets
from any UFC fights involving James
cross because the investigation is still
going on yeah for now
because if they're still investigating
and they do see they feel like there's
something fishy going on yeah that could
get dicey yeah and he got pulled from
his he's supposed to Corner fighter this
weekend you got a pool yeah last minute
tough for him right because he's making
money doing this he said he makes more
money on this than anything else so you
won't want to stop I just still train
the guys just don't Corner easy peasy
yeah
I don't know uh were you a Power Rangers
Fan at all uh no I know that guy passed
away yeah and by Suicide oh interesting
yeah he's only 49 years old that's a
bummer yeah Jason David Frank he was
looking Dude too
yeah he was like the most popular Power
Ranger was he the green one yeah
yep that sucks yeah who knows what the
story is but that yeah suicide
shitty
all right um this is just Conor McGregor
and Abu Dhabi I was talking to Casey
earlier like Conor without his facial
hair is so different looking it's such a
crazy thing he looks like Jesse on fire
but he's just he on fire it does
and he is sick dude he's really big yeah
and Abu Dhabi and he is thick man
so that means you can if you you if you
take yourself out of the testing you can
just do whatever you want and then just
come back in uh only Conor everybody
else it's getting a little dicey with
him I think there's it's so clear what
he's doing he's so jacked and big his
face all bloated but I'm with the UFC
I'm like do your thing whatever gets you
healthy you get fire away dude
as long as you're not competing then
that's fine I guess it's weird though
right it's super it's like a
like loophole
and he's the the one there that's where
he looks like Jesse no not that one go
over
yeah he's jacked on that one he just
showed but look at this look at me they
have swollen like that's I know and all
that stuff
it's just so strange
look how thick he is he's super thick
and but I mean his face is why I can't
get over
looks so trippy
it's like a different person
interesting right yeah I'm with UFC I'm
like do whatever you gotta do to get
that knee better man I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah if you're not competing I guess so
and then we talked about this not too
long ago
uh Conor McGregor's a bunch of people's
followings on Twitter
apparently a lot of them are fake
yeah we were we I sent this to the group
I said how many are faking how many did
they buy right yeah because how many are
Bots and how many did you actually buy
if you can buy I think it's a
combination of both I would imagine the
majority are Bots and with Elon taking
it over he's trying to get rid of those
Bots right so do you see Elon did this
thing I'm sure we'll talk about finding
the kid but Elon did this thing where he
put a poll up was like you want to see
Trump back it was like whatever
something like 54 48 or something like
that it was like
50 60 million people but he saw inflex
like influx of votes for no on uh not to
allow Trump act and they looked in there
there's a bunch of Bots okay
so he so one reason he did that so he
can go on there and look at all those
Bots and get one of them yeah
really smart
yeah who knows who knows what's going on
with this yeah they're showing some of
the
because I mean the people that are very
reputable too like Israel like DC
because they are not implying these
followers were bought just FYI yeah a
lot of them is fake so but if 50 of them
are fake I mean all these guys huge
names
like GSP too Nate Diaz khabib there's no
way you could be smart if I can follow
but this is 36.6 uh GSP and just all
these top guys have all these fake
callers apparently here's what's going
on either the people that control their
accounts for buying fakies along with
the Bots right and then also if you're
Connor this is how it works so if it's
Jesus Christ formula are fake um if
you're half on some guys if you're
Connor and you have 9.6 million
followers when you're doing those deals
with his whiskey and trust me I have to
deal with it when you're doing these
deals with the whiskey with Distributors
for him to go go buy my whisket whatever
his specs whatever and then go you buy
whatever a thousand cases and I'll
promote this to my 9.6 million followers
that's the benefit yeah but if you're
like hey it's 9.6 and like well it's
actually like more like five not nine
point six still uh yeah but 9.6 because
remember when they when especially even
when Instagram did the cleanup of their
followers Kim Kardashian lost a [ __ ] ton
yeah I don't think she's buying
followers just Bots I guess what the
boss there dude yeah I don't understand
the whole thing I don't know how do you
how can you buy it again I don't I don't
know how it works
yeah
yeah I don't know
to that list Jesus Christ so I went to
Connor's Instagram and I just looked at
his followers and then at the beginning
I was like just checking out like who
are these followers and some have zero
posts a lot of them when I was checking
them have zero posts but they have like
a certain amount of followers but
they're not they're not real those would
be Bob yeah so there's a ton of bots
weird yeah this is just Gilbert Burns
talking about hamzat I mean that the
UFC's not doing that yeah
and I think that's it I think that's it
yeah there's no fights coming up big
followers
and that card's really good that
December 3rd in uh Orlando Florida with
Thompson and Kevin Hollins a great card
Brian barbarino oh yeah that's popular
Matt schneel
tied to a boss of fighting Sergey Derek
Brunson Jack romance and Eric Sanders
Cal dacus it's great Fight Night card
Nico price on that [ __ ] Angel Hill yeah
Brian Ortega's girls fighting he got
clay Guida Scott Holtzman Michael
Johnson
Dan Elkins Tracy Cortez that's uh
Ortega's girl that's a good fight it's a
great card man for Fight Night fantastic
yeah it's what we need after a long
layoff yeah nothing else comes we'll get
that one comes yeah that's it
um well kids
that's it on our end
um Providence Rhode Island Rhode Island
I just figured out uh New England area
right Providence Rhode Island December
1st through the 3rd I had to cancel my
dates in DC I've been on the road damn
near
six weeks straight Non-Stop and the kids
have off from school I gotta reschedule
don't worry DC I'm coming back out there
um we'll figure it out we're gonna
re-announce uh dates for early 2023 in
DC one of my favorite markets but your
boy needs a break your boy needs a break
especially around the holidays so that's
the plan and I'll be with the kid I was
doing my thing but I'll still be doing
sets around La so uh if you're not at
the LA area coming out here on vacation
you can see me there on that next tour
date to end the Ohi thick tour in 2022
is in Providence Rhode Island December
1st through the 3rd that the common
connection we're almost sold out so get
your tickets now if you're thinking
about it get your tickets at
thickboy.com or fatkz.com all right then
we have some dates for 2023 on there but
uh Naples Oklahoma City Tacoma Spokane
we got a bunch more being announced but
for right now Providence Europe Rhode
Island come holler at your boy
um the thick Thursday is this
Thanksgiving this Thursday 6 a.m Pacific
Time thickboy.com or drop in the
official MLB military inspired jerseys
the brown and yellow jerseys hoodies
hats all that at thick boy.com that
award-winning sweet thick nectar say
five dollars off shipping you can get
the tiger thick on thick boy.com too all
right so it's all going down this thick
Thursday 6 a.m Pacific time so if you're
on the East Coast that's 9am for you
guys but it'll be all over all right
I'll be posting doing our thing
hopefully you guys have a great
Thanksgiving enjoy your family get off
your phones unless you're ordering uh
thick boy merch other than that get off
your phones enjoy your family enjoy that
dry ass turkey enjoy that stuff and
cranberry watch some football enjoy your
fam all right
all right kids be safe stay thick see
you next time
[Music]
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding